[Music]
now it's actually too early to really
have any hard and fast rules in VR I
think it's maybe like the Internet in
1998 where you could see that it was
coming but it's pretty hacked together
everything from the cameras the
stitching pipeline to the headsets
themselves they've been at this
prototype phase you know literally
taking GoPros and sticking them together
to make a 360-degree camera to manually
aligning images so they stitch correctly
and popping phones into plastic holders
I mean all of that is going away and is
being replaced with the real tools we're
getting real VR cameras we've built an
automated stitching pipeline and we're
gonna have headsets that are affordable
and easily accessible and so I think
we're really learning from just the the
difficulty of that the technical
challenges of creating VR and and some
of those challenges are melting away the
language of it is actually much harder
how do we use this effectively we're
finding things that do work we're
finding a lot of things that don't work
but we know that these experiences need
to be longer there have been pretty
short you know under 10 minutes we're
we're finding that the longer you spend
in VR and it has to be comfortable the
more immersion and feeling that you are
in that world the more your mind starts
to accept it and so we're creating
potentially 40 minutes of content up to
60 minutes where you can go in have
these long durations and come out and
have these you know profound experiences
within that time frame we know that the
visual fidelity needs to get much better
right now we're at four K by 2 K and
when stretched out at 360 degrees it
looks low res you know we need
resolutions of 8k by 4k frame rates 60
frames per second we need perfect
synchronization between all of these
cameras and ambisonics audio where an
audio source sounds
like it's actually coming from this
position when all of these factors start
combining we're gonna have these high
fidelity experiences where the fluidity
of a motion that can transfer in these
worlds is going to be unparalleled and
so I think we're just beginning on this
curve of VR where the technology the
storytelling they're starting to come
together where we're passing the
prototype phase and we can actually use
it to create these profound experiences
where people come out after you know
even ten minutes come out of a headset
and there they will say they're you know
I I was so moved by that and a year
later we'll come back and say that
experience changed my life and I and I
haven't heard that before in films and
images that a short experience can have
such a profound and lasting impact and
so I think there is this real potential
that we're just starting to crack but
right now it's a little bit of radio on
the television it's an entirely new
medium so a lot of the cinematic
language from traditional documentary
and cinema it has to be rethought in
this new medium of VR from the basics of
composition there is no frame you're
working a 360 degree environment cuts
are can be very abrupt and kind of take
time for the viewer to reorient
themselves in a new scene so even some
of these real basics change so we're
still learning what this language looks
like but we know it's very spacial you
are feeling like you're actually there
this sense of presence it can be very
strong you are starting to interpret
your brain is interpreting these scenes
as real and your body is reacting to
them as they're real as well so you can
have these very intense or meditative
experiences in VR depending on how you
use it
we first thought that the whole crew had
to disappear from a shot
and so we would set it up on a tripod
and everybody would leave and
get what we'd get but then you know that
was very limiting to shoot everything on
tripod we really wanted to move with the
camera and move with our subjects so we
decided to leave our camera operator in
the shot
carrying the VR camera which we really
streamlined in wait so that we could put
it on stabilized gimbal this allowed us
to move the camera through space which
hadn't really been done before in VR but
in a really comfortable way if it's
moving in a straight forward in a level
manner it's comfortable for the viewer
in the headset but it also really
heightens this sense of space when
you've got this much more information
passing by you you really start to feel
the environment but it also meant that
the camera operator was in the shot if
you look behind you
there he is holding the camera and you
know that broke the standard rule of no
crew and the shot but it really didn't
bother anybody it's just sort of yeah
that's the process of making VR it's 360
you can't hide everybody and he was just
part of the scene and some people really
enjoyed it they wanted to know sort of
what he was feeling in response to some
of the things that he was filming and
there he was taking them through so
here's that's just one example of where
we sort of discarded a rule that had
been established made a new one and I'm
sure new ones will replace that so we're
still constantly iterating on what works
and what's effective filming anything
that has the potential to be very
emotional that will transfer very well
in VR filming things that are hard to
access that you can't either travel to
or they're behind closed doors or
they're hidden on purpose and there's
just no visual record of him those are
very effective in VR you're experiencing
something completely new completely
novel and and that you otherwise never
would have so you know good access and
emotional story and then strong
characters always really take you into a
world and you know that those few things
are some of the block building blocks
that were working with
but we're still experimenting we're
still trying to understand this language
but we know it's very spatial it's very
emotional has the potential for these
profound experiences
[Music]